APPEARANCE.
HOW LONG CAN HE STAY OUT OF THE
LIMELIGHT?
THAT IS LATER.
FIRST, THE BOLTON RED HERRING.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
I’M BEGINNING TO THINK I AM A
COMPLETE MASOCHIST BECAUSE I WAS
BACK ON CAPITOL HILL TODAY TO
SAID FOR THE SECOND TIME IN THE
SENATE CALORIE AND OBSERVE THIS
TRAVESTY OF AN IMPEACHMENT
TRIAL.
WHILE OF COURSE IT WAS GREAT TO
HEAR FROM THE DEFENSE TEAM,
ESPECIALLY ALAN DERSHOWITZ.
I WALKED AWAY EVEN MORE
DISGUSTED OVER WHAT THE
DEMOCRATIC HOUSE HAS DONE TO
AMERICA.
IF IT’S EVEN POSSIBLE, I AM MORE
OUTRAGED THAT THE FOUR SQUISHY
SENATORS ARE TOYING WITH
PROLONGING THIS NATIONAL
NIGHTMARE.
IN A UTTERLY PREDICTABLE TURN,
THE RESISTANCE MEDIA WENT GAGA
WHEN WORD LEAKED THAT
JOHN BOLTON SUPPOSEDLY DROPPED A
BOMBSHELL.
A LEAKED SECONDHAND ACCOUNT OF
HIS UPCOMING BOOK.
THE MEDIA WAS SURE THAT THIS
WOULD ALTER THE COURSE OF
TRUMP’S IMPEACHMENT.
>> BOMBSHELL REVELATIONS FORM
THE FORMER NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR.
>> EXPLOSIVE NEW DETAILS.
>> IT HAS SHAKEN WASHINGTON.
>> IT HIT CAPITOL HILL LIKE A
THUNDERBOLT.
>> REPUBLICAN SENATORS ARE
FEELING BLINDSIDED.
>> IT COULD CHANGE THE COURSE OF
THE IMPEACHMENT TRIAL.
>> Laura: IT’S ALWAYS A GAME
GAME CHANGER, RIGHT?
WE GOT HIM NOW.
AS SOMEONE WHO HAS WRITTEN FIVE
BOOKS.
WORKING WITH SOME OF THE TOP
PUBLISHING HOUSES, I KNOW
HOW THIS LITTLE GAME GOES.
LET ME EXPLAIN IT TO YOU.
IT’S ALL ABOUT HYPE.
PUBLISHERS HAVE TO HYPE IF YOU
CHOICE TIBBETS IN DESPERATE
HOPES THAT THEY WILL MAKE BACK
THE ADVANCE THAT THEY PROBABLY
SHOULDN’T HAVE SHELLED OUT ON
THE FIRST PLACE.
NOTHING THAT JOHN BOLTON ARRIVES
AND A BOOK OR WOULD TESTIFY TO
DRIVE A SENATE TRIAL THE BASIC
FACTS THAT ALL 100 SENATORS
KNOWN.
LET ME GO THROUGH SOME OF THEM
WITH YOU.
NUMBER ONE, PRESIDENT TRUMP DID
SELL JAVELIN ANTITANK MISSILES
TO UKRAINE.
OBAMA NEVER DID.
>> HERE’S THE OTHER THING, THEY
GOT THEIR MONEY LONG BEFORE
SCHEDULED.
WHY ISN’T GERMANY PAYING?
WHY ISN’T FRANCE PAYING?
WHY ARE THE EUROPEAN NATIONS
PAYING?
WHY IS IT ALWAYS THE SUCKER, THE
UNITED STATES?
>> Laura: THAT IS EXACTLY HOW
HE CALLED ZELENSKY.
HITTING THE NATO MEMBER NATIONS
FOR NOT SHIPPING ANY MORE BREAD
THAT WAS ALL THE CALL STARTED.
NUMBER TWO, ON SEPTEMBER 25TH
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID MEET WITH
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT ZELENSKY AND
EXPRESSED HIS DESIRE TO DO SO ON
A NUMBER OF OCCASIONS BEFORE
THAT.
INCLUDING ON THE JULY 25TH PHONE
CALL.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP INVITED
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY.
APRIL 21ST ON MAY 29TH,
PRESIDENT TRUMP SENT A
CONGRATULATORY LETTER, INVITING
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY TO THE
WHITE HOUSE.
ON JULY 25TH, PRESIDENT TRUMP
PERSONALLY INVITED
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY TO
PARTICIPATE IN A MEETING FOR
THIRD TIME.
GIVE US A DATE AND WILL WORK
THAT OUT.
THREE SEPARATE IMITATIONS.
ALL MADE WITHOUT ANY
PRECONDITIONS.
>> Laura: FACT NUMBER THREE,
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT NEVER
ANNOUNCED AN INVESTIGATION INTO
THE BIDENS OR BREEZE MOUNT.
NUMBERS ONE AND TWO HAPPENED.
THE MEETING WITH ZELENSKY IN THE
MILITARY AID.
WITHOUT HIM EVER HAVING
ANNOUNCED HE WAS INVESTIGATING
THE BIDENS.
LET’S NOT FORGET, NUMBER FOUR.
ZELENSKY SAID HE WAS NOT
PRESSURED.
THE CALL WAS NORMAL.
ZELENSKY CONTRADICTED THE
DEMOCRATS WILD THEORY, SAYING HE
NEVER FELT PRESSURED TO CONDUCT
AN INVESTIGATION.
HE DIDN’T KNOW THE AIDE WAS HELD
UP.
THE DEMOCRATS ANSWER TO THAT
WAS -- LET’S CONSULT OUR ALLY.
>> PRESIDENT ZELENSKY DOESN’T
WANT TO BE USED AS A PAWN.
HE DOESN’T WANT TO BE DRAWN INTO
U.S. POLITICS.
AT THIS POINT HE FEELS LIKE HE
HAS NO CHOICE.
>> Laura: HE IS LYING.
THAT WAS A NICE WAY OF SAYING,
ZELENSKY WAS LYING.
NICE GOING.
IF DONALD TRUMP REALLY WANTED TO
HOLD A MILITARY AIDE FOR THE
INVESTIGATION OF UKRAINIAN
CORRUPTION, LET ME TELL YOU,
UKRAINE WOULDN’T HAVE THEIR
JAVELINS.
RIGHT NOW, THEY WOULDN’T HAVE
THEM.
WITH ZERO EVIDENCE OF CRIMINAL
INTENT ON THE PART OF THE
PRESIDENT, HE KNEW THAT 15
PEOPLE WERE LISTENING TO THIS
PHONE CALL ON JULY 25TH FOR
GOODNESS’ SAKES.
THE HOUSE HAD JUST LEFT WITH
HYPERBOLE, HEARSAY, AND
CONJECTURE.
ANY HONEST SENATOR KNOWS THAT
THE PRESIDENT’S 100% AND HIS
RIGHT AS CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER
OF THE UNITED STATES TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT CORRUPTION IN
FOREIGN AID.
WEATHER INVOLVES THE BIDENS WERE
DOESN’T INVOLVE THEM.
IF HE DECIDES THAT CERTAIN AIDE
NEEDS TO BE DELAYED A BIT WHILE
HE GATHERS MORE FACTS, SO BE IT!
IT’S HIS CALL.
HE WAS ELECTED PRESIDENT.
TO DO WHAT HE DID IS NEITHER
ILLEGAL NOR UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
REMEMBER, HE RAN ON SAFEGUARDING
OUR TAX DOLLARS.
AT NATO, IRAQ, EVEN IN
CENTRAL AMERICA.
>> THIS PAST SUMMER THE
ADMINISTRATION PAUSED, REVIEWED,
AND IN SOME CASES CANCELED
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN FOREIGN AID TO AFGHANISTAN,
EL SALVADOR, HONDURAS,
GUATEMALA, AND LEBANON.
AT THE VERY SAME TIME THAT THE
UKRAINE AID WAS PAUSED.
>> Laura: DID HE DO ALL OF
THAT TO HELP HIS REELECTION
CHANCES SO HE LOOKS LIKE HE’S
TOUGH ON IMMIGRATION?
DO YOU SEE THIS ARGUMENT COULD
GO?
SITTING BACK WATCHING THIS COME
OUT I WAS AT HOME, FROM DAY ONE
WHAT THIS IS REALLY ALL ABOUT IS
THAT THE GLOBALISTS IN IN THE OB
HOLDOVERS, IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION THAT WERE
BURROWED DEEP INSIDE WERE
INFURIATED BY HIM FROM DAY ONE.
DONALD TRUMP DARED TO CHALLENGE
THE STATUS QUO.
THE BLOATED FOREIGN AID TO
BUDGETS THAT SEND BILLIONS
OVERSEAS TO UNGRATEFUL, AND
CORRUPT NATIONS.
WE AT HOME ARE DRIVING OVER
RUSTED OUT BRIDGES AND WE FLY
OUT OF DILAPIDATED AIRPORTS.
MOST REGULAR PEOPLE GO, WE ARE
GIVING ALL THAT MONEY TO
UKRAINE?
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
LESS THAN TWO MONTHS AFTER HE
WAS SWORN IN, HE WAS ENRAGING
THE OLD FOREIGN POLICY
ESTABLISHMENT.
>> WE ARE GOING TO PROPOSE TO
REDUCE FOREIGN AID AND TO SPEND
THAT MONEY HERE.
>> Laura: CARRILLO, CAREER
CIVIL SERVANTS PREFER A WORLD WH
JUDGMENTS REIGN SUPREME.
THERE NEVER QUESTIONED.
THE BUDGETS KEEP GROWING AND
GROWING AND GROWING.
BECAUSE PEOPLE LIKE THAT, THEY
TEND TO FANCY THEMSELVES AS
GLOBAL SOPHISTICATES.
SMARTER THAN THE PRESIDENT,
SMARTER THAN YOU WILL.
AS FOR JOHN BOLTON, IT’S REALLY
DISAPPOINTING IF HE ENDS UP
BEING ANOTHER SYNC TANK-TYPE
TRYING TO CASH IN ON HIS TIME AT
THE WHITE HOUSE.
I LIKE BOLTON, HE HAS BEEN ON
THE SHOW A NUMBER OF TIMES.
HE’S A NEOCON WHO SHOULD HAVE
NEVER BEEN HIRED IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
AGAIN, AS YOU HEARD TONIGHT FROM
THE IMPEACHMENT TEAM, POLICY
DIFFERENCES SHOULD NOT LEAD TO
AN IMPEACHMENT.
THE ONLY REASON ANYONE CARES
ABOUT WHAT BOLTON HAS TO SAY IS
BECAUSE HE WAS TRUMP’S NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR, PERIOD.
WE DO NOT NEED TO HEAR FROM HIM
OR READ WHAT HE WRITES.
NONE OF WHAT HE COULD SAY AND
WRITE COULD CHANGE THE FACTS AS
THEY OCCURRED.
IT IS LONG PAST TIME TO PUT AN
END, A MERCIFUL AND TO THIS
FIASCO.
I SAY THIS BY THE WAY, DESPITE
THE FACT THAT IMPEACHMENT HAS
BEEN A HUGE RATINGS [BOOS]
TO "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" AND
FRANKLY ALL THE FOX NEWS DID IF
YOU ARE A SENATOR AND IF YOU
LISTEN TO BOTH SIDES PAST WEEK
AND YOU ARE TELLING US WHO
HAVEN’T DECIDED HOW YOU’RE GOING
TO VOTE?
RESIGN, YOU SHOULDN’T BE IN THE
SENATE.
WITH RARE EXCEPTION, THE SAME
FAMILIAR ARGUMENTS ARE BEING
MADE EVERY DAY.
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
>> EXCUSE ME, WHERE IS EVERYBODY
GOING?
>> TO GOBBLER’S KNOB, ITS
GROUNDHOG’S DAY.
>> IS STILL JUST ONCE A YEAR,
ISN’T IT?
>> Laura: IT’S ALMOST HERE.
IF ONLY THE TRIAL WAS ONE
ONE-HUNDREDTHS AS ENTERTAINING
AS THAT MOVIE.
IF ONLY BILL MURRAY WERE UP
THERE.
YOU GET THE SENSE THAT THE
HANDFUL OF MODERATE REPUBLICANS
ARE ENJOYING THEIR HAMLET
ROUTINE RIGHT NOW.
A LITTLE BIT TOO MUCH.
PEOPLE LIKE MITT ROMNEY, I’M
SURE THEY’RE GREAT PEOPLE,
NOTHING PERSONAL.
DO THEY CONSIDER THIS MOMENT?
A MOMENT TO SHOW CHUCK TODD THAT
THERE IS A GOOD REPUBLICAN, THE
RESPECTABLE REPUBLICANS, NOT
LIKE TRUMP.
LONG AFTER THEIR ONE NIGHT STAND
WITH THE LIBERALS, THEIR
CONSTITUENTS WILL SEE THEIR
POSTURING FOR WHAT IT IS.
A WALK OF SHAME.
ALLOWING THIS WORK IS TO
CONTINUE FOR MONTHS.
WE WILL BE HERE FOR MONTHS IF
THIS CONTINUES!
IT MEANS ALLOWING THE PEOPLE’S
BUSINESS TO LANGUISH.
IT’S A BAD MOVE.
LET’S URGE THEM TO CALL THE VOTE
NO.
THEY WANT TO VOTE TO CONVICT
TRUMP?
LIVE WITH THE CONSEQUENCES.
THE SENATE SWITCHBOARD’S 202-
202-202-3121.
WE WILL PUT THAT UP THROUGHOUT
THE SHOW TONIGHT.
I WANT YOU TO MAKE A PHONE CALL.
TELL THEM HOW YOU FEEL.
YOU ARE PAYING THEIR SALARY.
THEY WORK FOR YOU NOT THE OTHER
WAY AROUND.
AS FOR THE G.O.P. FENCE SITTERS,
I WILL PERSONALLY FLY OUT TO
COVER YOUR TOWN HALL.
I WILL BE THERE REPORTING ON
THEM.
IF YOU’RE BRAVE ENOUGH TO HAVE
ANY.
AFTER A VOTE TO DRAG THIS THING
OUT FURTHER.
UTAH HAS GOT TO BE EXPERIENCED A
WICKED CASE OF VOTER’S REMORSE
I’M SORRY.
BOLTON, A RED HERRING.
IT’S ALWAYS THE ENTIRE IDEA:
WITNESSES.
NANCY PELOSI’S DEMOCRATS
WOULDN’T PURSUE THOSE SAME
WITNESSES IN THE HOUSE,
CERTAINLY NOT TAKING A LEGAL
ROUTE.
IF YOU WANT TO REMOVE A U.S.
PRESIDENT ON THE FACTS THAT ARE
NOW INDISPUTABLE, YOU WANT TO DO
WHAT NINE MONTHS BEFORE AN
ELECTION?
IF YOU WANT TO SIDE WITH SCHIFF
AND JERRY NADLER OVER YOUR OWN
CONSTITUENTS?
YOUR CONSTITUENTS WHO ARE
ENJOYING A THRIVING ECONOMY AND
WANT GOVERNMENT TO GET BACK TO
THE STUFF THAT MATTERS!
BE MY GUEST, GO DO IT.
I HAVE ANOTHER IDEA.
JUST ASK JEFF FLAKE HOW LIFE IS
AFTER THE DEMOCRATS NO LONGER